Hi everyone, it's Jerry. This is a Round 11
game from the 2016 Tata Steel Chess Tournament,
Master's section, between Magnus Carlsen playing
on the white end, and Hou Yifan. These two
played for the first time in last year's Tata
Steel Tournament where Carlsen had the white
pieces. He's playing as white again in this
one. Let's see how things play out. e4 e5
knight f3, knight f6, the Petrov's Defense.
We have the Nimzovich Attack with knight c3.
Don't be mislead by the term 'attack'. We
have anything but that in this game. Things
are pretty uneventful in the opening and middlegame.
Several piece exchanges soon occur, and we
have an ending in this one soon coming about
where it's queen and bishop versus queen and
bishop. And shortly thereafter a king and
pawn ending alone. That part of the game is
the part that I found interesting. Knight
takes, d takes. Minor pieces out, getting
castled. White goes queenside, black prepares
queenside castle. b3, h3 looks to grab some
kingside space and complete development. Black
goes queenside. If black is going kingside
this is a much different ballgame. g4 a5 g5
each side going after the kings. Looking to
open files against the enemy king. Timing
will be a great factor. Not the case here.
We're not attacking one another's king. Queenside
castle, g4 h6 rules out g5. If g5 is played,
this is a favorable exchange for white* (black).
The h-pawn has been exchanged for the extremely
valuable g-pawn. White now has split pawns.
Bishop g2, king b8, white centralizes. So
too does black. King b2, a6. And now white
prepares to double on the e-file, the only
open file. And when that is the case, when
there is only one open file, it's not uncommon
for both sets of rooks to be exchanged. We
soon have both rooks exchanged in this one.
Queen e7, this seems a little bit awkward
to place the queen opposite the rook. But
this is only temporary. The queen's destination
is f8, and what she's basically doing...what
the queen is doing here is getting out of
the way of the light-squared bishop who had
no good moves from at this point here. So
the queen is getting out of the bishop's way
so he can move, and then the rooks can kind
of be offset. White doubles, queen f8, knight
d4. Several exchanges now. Knight takes, bishop
takes, bishop takes. How to recapture on d4?
Queen takes. You could go with the pawn. You're
not going to see a great shift in the evaluation.
And this is something I'd like to draw just
a little bit of attention to...this capture.
Because I believe many would just go with
the pawn. Seeing this as a moment to ya know...this
is my moment to undouble my pawns...let's
go for it. Queen takes is a move that I like.
I like having these pawns close to the king.
With the queens still on the board like this...this
configuration of pawns...and it doesn't show
up in this ending but it's worthwhile to note.
It could very well end up in plenty of other
endgame situations where you're still working...each
side is still working with a queen. This configuration
of pawns...the b3 c3 and c2 structure for
the white king is an excellent pocket to combat
a possible perpetual check by black. The b-pawn
stops any checks along the file, the c-pawn
is responsible for stopping the diagonal checks,
and the c-pawn stops rank checks. Compare
this with black, and their pawn structure.
They don't have that configuration. We could
one day...suppose these guys are no longer
around on the back rank. We could see the
queen bouncing back and forth on h8 and d4
to land a perpetual check to the king. Something
worthwhile to note. This is an asset in a
queen ending...this type of pocket for the
white king. It is not the same if this pawn
is here because he requires now the defense
of a piece other than the king. Anyhow, again
it's not something that shows up in this game...this
idea of a perpetual check, but it's worthwhile
to note. Okay, bishop d7. White grabs some
kingside space. Rooks are now exchanged, and
there's really not...there hasn't been much
going on in this game. It's pretty even. When
I bring up the graph, I'll show you...it'll
be saying that it's an ever so slight advantage.
But it could just as well be saying zero for
an evaluation. There isn't...there isn't much
to do. These next couple moves are examples
of just one move threats. Threatening mate
in one. These one move threats are just not
enough. They're easily addressed. It's when
there are two weaknesses, and if white is
able to pinpoint both weaknesses in one move...that
can be difficult to defend. But these one
move threats are again...easily addressed.
So, c6 defends. Bishop f1 threatens to take
a pawn since the b-pawn is pinned. Black gets
out of the pin. And just kind of fast forwarding
some...this is really all we have are these
one move threats. Queen attacks the pawn.
Counterattack against the bishop. The queen
is now here to secure these two points. What
are the only other sensitive points? It's
d6...the king will easily cover that. Bishops
are now off, and yeah. These are two vulnerable
points...the king can watch over here. The
queen has the other two. c4, king up, check,
and soon we have with this one the queens
being exchanged right here. And this is the
big moment in the game. Extremely important
moment for black. Black's on move here...move
45. Up until this point dead even just call
it. This next move there's an issue however.
There are 11 legal moves for black here. Only
one of them will hold this ending to a draw.
I wonder if you can spot it. What would you
do in this position as black? If you'd like
to...go ahead spend some time with this
one working it out. Try and find the drawing
idea for black in this king and pawn ending.
Okay, the drawing idea is a5. This is a must
move. This was not played in the game. The
move played was h5, and this allows white
to win. If I'm to just show the graph here...we
get an idea of how things played out all the
way up until move 45. Again, it'll be showing
a slight advantage, but this is nothing slight...ya
know...nothing significant I should say. Up
until this point king takes c3, .41. This
is a draw up until this point. An issue with
the next move h5, clearly. Let's see how things
played out after h5. How did white enter...well
how did white make progress? He entered by way
of b4 a5 and he really wants to get to b6.
Can he get there? Yes. Because he has these
tempi in reserve. He can eventually force
black into zugzwang...into a position where
he kind of has to concede something. He has
to give ground. Black has to give up control
of b6. And this is a big deal. If the white
king could post up here, he's exerting pressure
on both black pawns, and tied in with this
b5 break, black has to give up both the a
and c pawn. So from here we had h4. King goes
back already. If d4 is played, well white
still has another move here, b4 and then the
king has to go back. So in the game black
just went back right away. King b6, and now
this is the idea...b5 takes takes, takes again,
king c7, and after c3 black (Hou Yifan) resigned. There's
nothing to do here. Superior king position.
What's soon to happen is the c and b pawn
will be exchanged, and then white could simply
walk along the 5th rank and pick up all the
other black pawns. Suppose king d7, king b6,
king c8, c6, takes takes, and then you get
the idea. There might have been one cute finish
if things played out. If they took it further...we
could have had a...an interesting ending where
after c6, king b8. This is still winning for
white. c takes b, still winning. Black king
can't move. There's only one legal move with
d4. If you take it's stalemate, but you can
actually push and allow black to queen first,
but in the end you're mating with a pawn.
This did not happen...again after c3 black
(Hou Yifan) resigned. So what was the drawing
idea? It was a5, but why? Why does a5 draw,
and nothing else draw? Well what's the trick
with this? a5 first off...it stops king b4,
but really the deeper idea, and the main idea
here with a5 is to stop the king from entering
on b6. This is what a5 prevents white from
doing. You cannot get your king to b6. If
you can't get to b6, you're not winning this
game. The only other key square...b6 is a
key square, it's a potential entry point for
the white king...so too is e5. If white ever
tries to get to e5, well that's easily prevented
by king e6. And notice that black has two
squares that he can continually move to. He
can bounce back and forth on e6 and f6. And
what is he doing constantly? Watching over
the key square e5. After a5, b4...suppose
b4. This is the idea by black...keep the pawn
on a5 sitting. h5, takes...if you're not taking
the pawn and playing here, you're not making
any progress on this side of the board now,
and the only key square to watch over is e5,
and that's easily guarded. If we take stock
of all the squares the black pawns control...b4
c4 e4 d5. The white king can never go here...that's
another square, another one. This is the only
entry, and again it's easily guarded. So b5
doesn't do anything. The only thing to test
out is this capture. After let's say h4, king
b4, king c7. a6 is the only try to open up
the a5 square. But notice something...after
a6, black replies...black's reply I should
say...does two things. One, captures a pawn...okay
we see that, but two...it opens up a new square
for the black king...b7. So after a5, there's
king b7, and what has...what has transpired
here? Well with this new square opened up,
black has...similar to this idea over here...when
trying to watch over the e5 square. Black
has two squares he can move back and forth
to, and always be controlling the key square
b6. Just as he was doing over here when the
white king tries to enter the e5 square. The
king can continually move...there's endless...endless
tempi. An infinite amount of tempi that the
king could use, and you're always watching
these key squares. And this is...this is really
the trick here with this a5 idea. Ya know
if white is going to enter in this direction,
they're going to have to take, and then eventually
do this a6 push to open up the a5 square.
But you open up the a5 square for the king...after
b takes a, there's now a new square opened
up for the black king. What happened in the
game? We got to this point here where there
is, unfortunately for black, not two squares
for the king to continually bounce back and
forth to to watch over b6. That's the big
trick here. This a5 idea eventually...the
tempos are all exhausted by black, and he
has to concede ground...he has to give up
the b6 square. He's in zugzwang. a5 idea eliminates
this little trick here. It doesn't allow white
to place black in zugzwang...playing this
a5 idea. These endgames are tricky. King and
pawn endings, there's a lot of calculation
needed. You have to be extremely careful with
how you use your tempi, and one wrong slip
as we saw in this one...playing h5 instead
of a5, and the game was thrown away. Anyhow...I
hope you found...well not the opening or middlegame
but this king and pawn ending instructive.
And as usual...if you have any comments you'd
like to leave in the comments section below,
feel free to do that. And, I hope you got
something out of this video. That's all for
now. Take care, bye.